bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7-8 lecture
le journal de la rédaction chaque soir
en direct à 18 heures du lundi au
vendredi voici les titres de ce mardi 29
avril saint quentin en yvelines un
nouveau visage celui de michel laugier
le maire centre-droit de montigny le
bretonneux succède donc au socialiste
robert cadalbert il est l'invité du
journal il reviendra sur la nouvelle
organisation
l'a2 à l'agglomération jean marie cavada
marielle de sarnez tête de liste
alternative en ile de france les deux
formations partent ensemble pour la
campagne après la division des
municipales et puis un élan cour vient
de se tenir un forum pour inciter les 11
25 ans à bouger pratiquer un sport oui
mais lequel des associations données et
des conseils aux familles samedi dernier
au gymnase chastagner l'image du jour à
présent c'est à saint nom la bretèche le
comédien plébiscité par le public et
dany boon en pleine partie de golf et
c'est pour la bonne cause il est le
parrain de mécénat chirurgie cardiaque
il participait à un trophée solidaire
qui chaque année permet de récolter des
fonds afin d'aider des enfants souffrant
de malformations du coeur à venir en
france et être opéré lorsqu'ils ne
peuvent pas être soignés dans leur pays
d'origine par manque de moyens
financiers techniques mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque a déjà aidé plus de 2000
enfants depuis sa création en 1996 le
trophée du golf solidaire fait sa 17e
édition on écoute dany boon c'est une
histoire de coups de coeur et après de
dire d'espoir fin après je verrai s'il
faut c'est là disponibles pour pour
aider l'association et m mettre ma
notoriété au service de de la récolte de
fonds quoi
reportage complet sur la manifestation
le travail de mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque ce sera demain même heure sur
tv fils politique à présent à la maison
jean monnet père de l'europe est
symboliquement udi modem ont présenté
leur liste commune pour ce scrutin des
européennes dont l'unique tour se
déroulera le dimanche 25 mai 4 in the
late auclair cambier et jonathan vilma
lui dit et le modem sous la même
bannière pour dire oui à l'europe et
affirmé leur euro optimisme on a besoin
vitalement d'europe pour aller créer
notre propre croissance pour aider pour
l'emploi pour avoir de nouveaux outils
de nouveaux instruments par exemple de
mobiliser l'épargné européenne pour les
grands travaux par exemple qu'on a
besoin d'une politique européenne en
matière d'immigration avec des
frontières extérieures de l'europe
qu'ils soient gardés avec un corps de
garde côtes donc une politique
européenne on a besoin de plus d'europe
pour la défense pour la politique
étrangère la liste udi modem présente 12
engagements pour l'europe autour de
trois thèmes majeurs l'emploi avec une
politique industrielle à définir la
démocratie avec la volonté de donner
plus la parole aux habitants par le
biais d'initiatives citoyennes et la
protection les centristes entendent
ainsi mettre un terme à la politique
d'élargissement des frontières un
programme construit qui cherche aussi à
convaincre les français de l'étranger
car pour cette élection ils sont invités
à voter dans la circonscription de l'île
de france 2 millions sont inscrits il
faut donc les séduire les parmi les
colistiers un yvelinois bruno myle yen
qui a vécu à l'étranger le regard qu'ont
les pays étrangers à la fois sur la
france à la fois sur l'europe girex et
des regards teinte et d'émerveillement
avec de petites étoiles dans les yeux et
j'ai envie que ce rêve là qui existent à
l'étranger vis-à-vis l'europe et de la
france existe aussi en france moi je
suis absolument
un catastrophé mais déçu de voir autant
de populisme de monter en france
vis-à-vis de l'europe aux tribunaux à
présent sur cette liste de 30 candidats
flavien base - conseil municipal
d'opposition udi à jouy en josas soutenu
par le patron départemental
c'est une liste extrêmement engagé de
gens qui sont pétris d'europe qui se
consacre au fond leurs tripes wallace
alors certains il ya eu des témoignages
avait vu ont dit qu'ils avaient il était
né avec cette europe faut passer une
marche supplémentaire pour à plus de
cohésion sociale les policiers
souhaitent mener une campagne de terrain
une réunion publique se tiendra le 20
mai à versailles le temps presse les
élections européennes se joue à un seul
tour le dimanche 25 mai
et j'ajoute qu'alain lamassoure tête de
liste ump également en ile-de-france
était lui à bougival cet après midi dans
les locaux et d'emmaüs un débat y était
annoncée à sur les thèmes des fonds
européens alloués à l'europe sociale et
autres formations en campagne dans le
département des yvelines le front de
gauche la numéro 2 de la liste en
ile-de-france raquel garrido rendra
visite aux salariés de l usine psa de
poissy demain à mercredi midi je reçois
présents michel laugier bonsoir bonsoir
le président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin officiellement élu donc samedi
matin bienvenue sur ce plateau lors de
votre premier discours vous avez
notamment évoqué le contexte économique
vous voulez rigueur responsabilités en
termes de ressources et de charges et
vous avez déclaré notamment il faudra
certainement recentrer nos énergies sur
le coeur même de nos compétences et de
nos missions aujourd'hui quelles sont
ses compétences et ses missions qui sont
prioritaires pour vous à l'agglomération
lors déjà la première chose c'est de
faire un véritable état des lieux
puisque nous arrivons aux commandes de
cette agglomération qui était gérée
pendant de très nombreuses années
par
une majorité socialo-communiste donc
aujourd'hui on doit déjà faire un
véritable état des lieux et puis ensuite
pour repartir bien sûr sur des bases
solides des bases de nouvelles des bases
solides vous avez déjà déterminé tout de
même des priorités les priori là avant
même d'avoir les résultats de l'église
les priorités déjà en premier lieu c'est
d'avoir un nouveau pacte financier
savait que on s'est entendus entre les
sept communes et la communauté d'agglo
en 2010 pour repartir sur des bases
financières nouvelles puisque la change
dans le décompte nous avait indiqué qu'
on ne pouvait plus financer des
équipements communaux sur le budget
communautaire donc ode à signer ce pacte
financier ce pacte financier qui devait
se terminer en 2013 on l'a prolongé
d'une année donc moi ma première mission
c'est de redéfinir ces nouvelles bases
afin que nous sachions chacun où nous
allons et je souhaite qu'on y travaille
rapidement pour qu'il soit intégré au
budget 2015 qui normalement sera votée
en fin d'année ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est de
effectivement à partir d'un état des
lieux de revoir un petit peu ce qui
fonctionnait bien ce qui pourrait mieux
fonctionner et peut-être donner des
priorités sur les compétences qui sont
les nôtres aujourd'hui allez peut-être
vers de nouveaux besoins notre société
évolue il est normal aussi que nous
évoluions et puis il ya aussi la
question du périmètre parce que là ce
sont des textes nouveau voté par le
gouvernement actuel qui nous oblige
aujourd'hui à réfléchir sur un
territoire qui sera plus important
puisque on doit passer de 148 mille
habitants à plus de deux cent mille
habitants donc là aussi c'est une
priorité puisque il faut que cette
nouvelle agglomération soit en place au
1er janvier 2016 d'envoyer que le temps
presse le l'écho républicain pardon
parler d'un mandat de l'expansion on l'a
bien compris c'est un mandat de
l'expansion aussi bien déjà en termes de
développement de saint quentin en
yvelines sur un plan économique parce
qu'il faut conforter ce pôle économique
qu'est l'agglomération que sur le plan
territorial vous avez déjà commencé à y
répondre mais juste su revenir sur les
priorités la priorité c'est de maintenir
le budget en faisant des économies vous
lancer un audit avec une volonté de
faire des économies est ce qu'il ya des
démissions
drs qui a déjà des choses que vous
imaginez devoir couper réduire avant de
dire il faut couper certaines choses ont
confié l'avoir d'audit complet et c'est
à partir de ce mois là lorsque nous
aurons tous les éléments que nous
pourrons faire des choix je vais pas
anticiper sur les choix en tout cas vous
savez très bien que on a pour mission
aussi d'avoir un développement
économique important parce qu'il faut
qu'on crée de nouvelles richesses donc
pour simplement pour arriver à compenser
aujourd'hui les dotations qui fondent
comme neige au soleil qui nous venaient
jusqu'à présent de l'état donc certes on
a eu des dettes importantes aujourd'hui
qui va falloir aussi diminué de manière
conséquente mais il va falloir aussi
trouver de nouvelles recettes pour
compenser les dotations par exemple
qu'ils nous devaient de plus de l'état
et lors de votre discours vous avez
beaucoup insisté ce sont des messages
rassurants vers les entreprises envers
les investisseurs ils sont les bienvenus
à 50 ans c'est le message que voulait
faire passer le message que je veux
faire passer surtout c'est que s'il ya
une alternance politique aujourd'hui
c'est une nouvelle équipe je veux
rassurer tous ceux qui ont travaillé ou
qui souhaitent travailler avec cette
agglomération ont promis lieu déjà toute
l'équipe administrative de la communauté
d'agglo il ya aujourd'hui deux nouvelles
directions donc il était important qu'il
ce que les collaborateurs soient
rassurés je souhaite rassurer aussi les
chefs d'entreprises qui sont là ils
savent très bien que depuis longtemps
moi je travaille avec eux j'ai souhaité
que jean michel fourgous soit le premier
vice président en charge du
développement économique je crois que
c'était aussi très fort aussi on sait
très bien que il est tout à fait à
l'aise sur ce domaine là et puis je
souhaite aussi rassuré les investisseurs
parce que on a aussi besoin aujourd'hui
d'avoir des investisseurs qui viennent
on a des mètres carrés encore à
valoriser sur saint-quentin dont je
souhaite aussi qu'ils soient rassurés
sur le comportement que nous aurons à
leur égard il ya des locaux
d'entreprises aujourd'hui à 50 ans même
si des nouveaux secrets qui sont vides
il va falloir remplir éventuellement il
y à des locaux qui sont vides il y à des
entreprises et qu'ils cherchent je crois
que il va falloir là aussi qu' on puisse
mettre en phase les personnes qui
souhaitent venir à saint quentin et d'où
que l'on puisse se favoriser leur
implantation il ya aussi j'allais dire
des zones d'activités rénové à
redynamiser je parle par exemple du nu
que je connais bien qui est sur le pas
du lac à montigny le bretonneux regardez
l'arrivée de mercedes et bien c'est
vraiment le départ de ce que nous
voulons faire c'est à dire avoir un parc
d'entreprises qui se renouvelle et on a
fait aussi la même chose de sûre
guyancourt avec lille the stars sur
l'avenue du centre bell je souhaite que
l'on continue comme ça sur la totalité
des communes on a un territoire qui
attractif il suffit il faut nous sommes
aujourd'hui persuadé que en renforçant
cette attractivité on fera venir encore
de nouvelles entreprises qui vont nous
apporter de nouvelles recettes et qui
vont nous permettre aussi de continuer à
développer à accueillir de nouvelles
populations à construire de nouveaux
logements tout ça dans un environnement
équilibré justement la population
puisque nous avons parlé développement
économique développement géographique
aussi de saint quentin en yvelines mais
la population quatre ans elle tout
simplement de cette nouvelle couleur
donnée à l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines voici quelques
réponses recueillies aujourd'hui
on verra bien moi je peux pas dire
d'avant ça mais comme le maire à la
nouvelle maire de voisins et pas
vraiment à droite c'est un peu
particulier quoi et b absolument rien
étant donné que pour moi la gauche la
droite c'est exactement pareil du coup
les seules choses qui auraient pu
changer c'est un peu les politiques
sociales mais sur la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin
je pense pas que ça va trop changé
peut-être sur les logements sociaux je
ne sais pas mais dans le fond je pense
que ça sera franchement pas grand chose
saint quentin en yvelines pas
personnellement du coup mendiants je
trouve qu'il ya un peu trop d'immigrés
voilà alors cet indépendant du
changement ce qu'on attend en général
c'est que la circulation soit fluide le
matin et le soir
ça me dit rien je ne serais même pas
quoi vous répondre
visiblement les jambes ça ne va pas
changer grand chose dans leur quotidien
en tout cas ils n'attendent pas de grand
changement si ce n'est sur la question
des transports j'aimerais votre réaction
on a aussi entendu parler de la question
de l'immigration avec cette réponse dans
des habitants de saint quentin alors
suivez le territoire
saint quentin est très diversifiée et
qu'elle même donc nous on va essayer de
travailler avec l'ensemble des des
communes parce que pour moi la réussite
de saint quentin sera la réussite de
chaque commune et là elle a réussi de
chaque commune fera le succès aussi de
l'agglomération de 50 on le voit bien la
référence immédiate pour les habitants
c'est pas forcément l'intermodalité mais
c'est leur mairie on l'a bien vu lors
des élections municipales
donc on voit bien c'est là quelque chose
donc c'est pour ça que on a tout intérêt
nous aussi c'est pour ça que j'ai
souhaité garder un conseil des maires
j'ai souhaité avoir un travail aussi
partagé avec chacune de ces communes
maintenant on va donner un ton nouveau
va donner des directions nouvelles et on
va essayer justement peut-être de
répondre à différentes questions en
sachant que les transports et oui les
transports s'était même fondamental sauf
que c'est même pas de la compétence de
la communauté d'agglo tous les cas pour
les pour les grandes lignes pour
l'amélioration des dessertes
ferroviaires puisque c'est au niveau du
stif donc on va essayer de peser encore
plus sur le stif et je compte bien sur
la vice présidente en charge des
transports qui est aussi conseiller
régional de nous obtenir quelques
résultats ce niveau là quelle place
justement pour l'opposition au sein de
cette nouvelle agglomération vous avez
souhaité conserver l'ouverture qui avait
été lancé est en tout cas initial déjà
sous la précédente mandature avec robert
cadalbert oui les choses devaient bien
fonctionné donc je trouve que c'était
très bien de pouvoir continuer donc
c'est pour ça que chaque ville
aujourd'hui à une vice-présidence sur
les 4 3 seront représentés par leur mère
et drew que guy malandain lui a préféré
laisser la place à une autre personne
dans un gang qui est la neuvième
vice-présidente en charge donc elle est
élue attrapa aux côtés de guy malandain
et elle était elle est à paris 9ème et
c'est justement une réflexion que je
m'étais fait en regardant un petit peu
l'organisation de l'agglomération vous
étiez le premier vice président sous la
précédente mandature de l'opposition
vous étiez le 5ème vice-président
aujourd'hui la première vice-présidence
est accordée au 9e vice-président est ce
qu'il faut y voir un signe pas il n'y a
pas de signe vous savez il ya je pense
que il ya un président il ya des vice
présidents se rappelle du premier puits
après vous savez c'est comme au niveau d
argent de l'ordre c'est comme au niveau
des adjoint donc un moment après il faut
savoir faire une liste la liste est
faite et après chaque président a la
même valeur on va écouter à présent l'un
des représentants de l'opposition
françois de ligne et le maire de
guyancourt à l'issue du conseil de
samedi matin concernant l'ouverture est
juste que c'est bien justement mais que
l'on pouvait mieux faire on aurait pu
aller encore plus loin dans le partage
de la gouvernance par exemple vous avez
vu que sur les vice présidents il ya des
places donné avec des réelles délégation
à la gauche néanmoins en proportion
faible surtout quand on pense que trois
délégués sont ajoutés et uniquement pour
la droite donc on commence avec un bon
principe mais on n'applique pas jusqu'au
bout ça sera notre rôle de veiller à ce
qu'ils soient mieux appliquées en tout
cas nous y prendrons toutes d'autre part
après j'ai noté qu'il y avait une
volonté de continuité par rapport à la
préservation de la réussite de saint
quentin en yvelines je dois dire à titre
personnel que juste ce serait très très
attentif à la poursuite des services de
qualité auprès des habitants est ce que
nous sommes là pour les habitants
j'ajoute également que
j'ai trouvé des manques c'est sur la
question de la culture
l'avenir par rapport à la culture compte
tenu des déclarations antérieures dans
le mandat précédent je serai là aussi
très très attentif à voir que le
dispositif culturel je pense notamment à
l'aide aux associations aux compagnies
au fonctionnement des équipements
culturels sont importantes dès lors que
ça a été rappelé nous sommes ville d'art
et d'histoire et nous sommes aussi ville
de culture michel logis vos réponse à
françois de ligne et concernant
l'ouverture qui aurait pu aller plus
loin ou encore sur ses compétences de la
culture aussi et les subventions
accordées aux associations oui alors je
vais peut-être rappeler françois des
lignes et ce qui se passait il encore y
encore quelques années puisque
l'opposition n'avaient pas droit de cité
dans l'exécutif donc aujourd'hui
nous avons été ils s'y sont on a
souhaité nous réduire parce que avoir
des délégations données à des personnes
qui ne viennent jamais ce n'est pas non
plus significative donc voix j'ai
souhaité que tout le monde soit vraiment
au travail c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
j'ai supprimé tout le système des
différentes commissions j'ai recentré
sur quatre commissions aujourd'hui pour
que tout le monde puisse bien participé
à la décision d'envoyer au niveau de la
gouvernance et de la participation j'ai
souhaité que tout le monde est soit
d'ailleurs dans ces commissions
réglementaire met dans la majorité et la
minorité sont représentés il savait il
ya une voix d'écart dons pour vous dire
que j'ai souhaité que la colle à valence
ce soit là donc j'ai pas forcément de
leçon à recevoir d'autres je pense que
la démocratie elle est appliquée de
manière tout à fait tout à fait forte
sur 50 temps à la culture c'est quand
même c'est quand même là le comble parce
que ça fait plusieurs années que nous on
réclame nous dit sur la culture que l'on
a jamais eu donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
eu des dépositions où on n'a plus
participé aux décisions ce qui concerne
la culture parce qu'on manquait de
l'information aujourd'hui certains
semblent dire que tout ce qu'il faisait
était bonne ou non nous c'est pas c'est
pas ça du tout on verra comment
cette culture et été organisées jusqu'à
ce jour et vous savez la ville de
montigny en ce qui concerne la culture à
la ville et qui met le plus de budget
pour ce secteur là donc je pense que je
suis très attaché à la culture et je
ferai en sorte aussi que la culture
garde douteux toute sa place à
l'intérieur de l'agglomération de saint
quentin mais sûrement avec d'autres
priorités notre priorité on en revient à
la question que je vous pose est tout à
l'heure on attendra les résultats de
l'audit aussi globale pour voir quels
sont les signes que vous allez lancer
sur sur l'agglomération de saint quentin
une dernière question vous avez tout à
l'heure évoqué ce conseil des maires on
aime en savoir un petit peu plus sur son
fonctionnement et son rôle donc ce sont
uniquement les mères qui se réunissent
donc on va juste rappeler qu'à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines il est encore quatre communes à
gauche et trois doigts 3 à droite donc
vous allez être en minorité au sein de
ce conseil des maires on attendait le
conseil des maires est là pour donner
des orientations savait jusqu'à présent
là on parle toujours de chiffres et de
proportions je rappelle que dans le
précédent mandat
il y avait trois villes de droite qui
représentait la grande majorité de la
population de saint quentin b si on
commence à jouer avec les chiffres on
peut leur faire tout dire moi ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'il y ait du respect
qu'il y ait de la considération qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient là au niveau du
conseil des maires pour qu'on puisse se
prendre les bonnes orientations qu'on
puisse avoir les décisions qui vont dans
le bon sens pour les communes et pour
notre agglomération comme ça il est mais
on n'a pas de pouvoir ce sont des
indications des réflexions qui sont
lancés ce sont des indications mais ce
sont aussi des positions se sont aussi
des dépositions mais jusqu'à présent ça
n'a pas posé de problème quand les
maires de droite était dans la minorité
dont font pas pourquoi sans poserait
parce que les maires de gauche serait
dans de minorité merci michel laugier
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin et mr bien sûr de montigny le
bretonneux est revenu ce soir merci
bonsoir autre sujet dimanche 27 avril
ont commémoré les victimes de la
déportation à bois d'arcy la cérémonie a
été marquée par la présence d'anciennes
victimes et de résistants également
olivier maniscalco anthony rech
une journée pour ne pas oublier ce
week-end une commémoration en souvenir
des déportés de la guerre 39-45 se
tenait à l'hôtel de ville de bois d'arcy
une cérémonie en hommage aux disparus et
aux victimes de la barbarie nazie un
moment de recueillement pour les copains
tombés au combat tant que je sai mouk
j'y reviendrai je leur dois
parce que ils sont tous morts
j'ai eu de la veine
jeu pur je suis ramené une chance
formidable témoignage des souffrances de
de mon père et puis de la mienne
également quoi parce que comme on dit
maintenant
la différence sera par contre de tous à
témoigner de l'horreur de la guerre et
raconter son parcours de combattant
c'est ainsi l'occasion de transmettre
aux plus jeunes une histoire et des
valeurs mêmes enfants on se rend bien
compte du sacrifice de ses aînés c'est
quelque chose d'important quoi c'est
comme des des votes sont morts c'est par
ces mariages avaient laissé leur vie ils
ont fait ça pour la france quoi donc
voilà je trouve que c'était bien de
enfin de se lever tôt va dire pour
rendre hommage aux personnes qu'ils ont
libéré la france et aux personnes qui
sont mortes pour nous ça soit des
enfants ou des adultes ils ont fait ce
combat pour libérer leur france la
liberté cette année marque le 60e
anniversaire de la journée nationale de
la déportation en france durant la
seconde guerre mondiale près de 160
mille personnes ont été déportées
inscrire ses enfants au sport une bonne
idée encore faut-il trouver la
discipline idéale à elancourt vient de
se tenir à un forum sport et santé pour
inciter les 11 25 ans à bouger et
yolaine thorez anthony rech
le sport la santé et les jeunes au coeur
d'un forum organisé par le service
jeunesse d'elancourt suite à une enquête
qu'elle a mené la ville a voulu informer
et pousser les jeunes à pratiquer une
activité sportive je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait quand même beaucoup
d'accidents au travers du sport et que
certaines certaines populations certains
certains jeunes restaient malgré tous
les clubs présents sur la ville encore
un petit peu en retrait et du coup ne
pratique pas de sport
bouger oui mais il faut savoir bien le
faire et pour donner les bons conseils
tout un panel de professionnels de santé
étaient au rendez vous une des premières
règles pour un sportif savoir gérer son
alimentation j'essaye c'est pas facile
se bat quand les jeunes on sent beaucoup
aussi et
c'est pas facile mais je leur dis que
c'est vraiment important de bien
s'hydrater tout au long de l'année de
bien manger de fonds de l'année mais
surtout la semaine précédente parce que
la géorgie s'ils ont bien mangé la
veille c'est sûr que ça va être mieux
mais c'est pareil dans toute la semaine
ils ont fait plein des carrés ils ont
pas beaucoup but sera bien gratter ils
vont reprennent des séquelles donc c'est
pourtant aura des conséquences en tout
cas des les contre-performances fraude
contre performance rime alors avec
mauvaise alimentation mais pas seulement
sur le forum une psychologue a également
alerté sur les addictions qui ne font
jamais bon ménage avec la pratique
sportive
plus le tabac
le tabac mais bon il ya aussi la colle
l'alcool est souvent une addiction pour
laquelle on a plus de mal à parler donc
le tabac c'est quand même socialement
quelque chose qui est admis donc on
vient souvent nous voir pour arrêter de
fumer et puis dans l'entretien on se
rend compte au bout d'un certain temps
où le patient devient effectivement
qu'il ya aussi un problème d'alcool
lors de ce forum parmi la vingtaine
d'exposants dix associations sportives
élan courtoise en ont aussi profité pour
faire découvrir leurs disciplines
c'est ce matin que les noms des lauréats
français du prix international de l'eau
juniors on était dévoilé un prix est
décerné par l'institut international de
l'eau de stockholm lycéens étudiants en
bts qui sont invités chaque année à
proposer leurs travaux de recherche
scientifique pour répondre aux enjeux de
l'eau dans le monde quatre jeunes de
seconde générale élèves du lycée hoche à
versailles distingué pour avoir réalisé
une maquette de stations d'épuration
communicante pouvoir ensuite mobiliser
un public plus large prochaine étape ce
sera la finale mondiale dont vous voyez
les images de la précédente édition en
septembre à 20 mille dollars en jeu dont
5000 pour l'établissement lauréats
ministre de l'éducation nationale de
l'écologie dû développement durable mais
également de la recherche de
l'enseignement supérieur soutiennent
cette initiative
rappelons que l'organisme qui attribue
ses prix aux plus jeunes distingue aussi
leurs aînés le stockholm water prize est
considérée comme le nobel tout
simplement de l'eau merci de nous avoir
suivis prochaine édition du journal
demain mercredi vous pouvez consulter
les précédentes éditions précédents
reportages sur notre site internet grâce
au replay excellente soirée vous avez
notamment rendez vous sur tv fils ce
soir avec catherine plateau pour le 7-8
société ait de débat à suivre sur l
avenir de l'université de versailles
saint quentin à demain
vous